on a typical day at John F Kennedy
Airport there are thousands of people
going hundreds of places excuse me sorry
my battery keeps dying I pour mine if
you want but today a girl and a boy will
meet
sorry I don't know share Electronics
till the third date okay now I suppose
it is quite intimate and it will change
everything
over the next six hours and 47 minutes
Hadley Sullivan and Oliver Jones will
fall in love this is me this is
unexpected
I've always hated airplanes and why are
you on a seven hour flight to London a
wedding do you it's a bit complicated
make our first day dinner in a Cheesy
rom-com or is that like a third date
thing for you
I'll be reaching for you I'll bring you
all my rules for you
the odds of finding your soulmate are
slim to none this is my number text me
so I've got yours
I don't know the odds are finding them
again
good luck
how's your flight surprising I lost his
number but I need to find this guy that
I met on the plane sounds really stupid
sounds Brave
with miles and miles between them there
is only a 0.2 chance that they will ever
see each other again
but what good is a chance
if you don't take it
[Music]
are we going to talk about that you
could be anywhere but I can't stop
thinking about her you won't find her
just sitting here is everything all
right I have to go
I didn't even see this coming love is a
lot of work it makes no sense it's not
supposed to
is it better to have had a good thing
and lost it or never to have had it
[Music]
do like a tech bro or I'm studying
statistics at Yale subtle status drop
there British you know I can't help
myself
I'm falling for you
[Music]